hey what's up guys my name is
today we're going to be taking a look at
ghost of tsushima what i've heard is an
absolutely amazing
game so i ran a quick poll on twitter to
figure out what to look at next and you
guys voted for ghost of
tsushima now as always i don't really
have much of an idea at what it is i'm
going to be
looking at from what i've heard about
this game though it's
absolutely amazing i know that it's set
in japan in the time of the samurai
i absolutely love japan i love all
things japan my honeymoon was in japan
and i just absolutely fell in love with
the country i really am
excited to take a look at this i found
this 18 minutes of ghost off sushima
gameplay i'll leave a link in the
description below if you want to watch
that first because i'll probably
end up pausing and talking about this
now in terms of what i want to focus on
when i'm looking at this i'm going to be
specifically focusing on the graphics
as well as the general interaction
between the player and the environment
so
essentially the gameplay as a game
engine developer it's obviously very
easy to just look at graphics as just
oh okay well this either looks good or
it looks bad and that's the end of the
story but obviously there's a lot more
to a game
than graphics and i don't want to just
be looking at the graphics although that
is
you know in the course of this fairly
short video that i'm making
the graphics is probably the biggest
thing that's going to stick out about
whether or not i'm going to be impressed
by this game
also even though this is technically a
reaction because i've never seen this
video
before i i mean i i want to steer away a
little bit from the direction of just
reaction videos i promise you i wouldn't
make too many of them and it seems like
i am you and me we're just here to sit
down look at this amazing gameplay from
what i've heard
and just have a good time so let's just
forget about the whole reaction stuff
let's just
let's just check it out
[Music]
hello everyone i'm jason connell from
sucker punch productions
we have a lot to show you today about
ghost of tsushima
combat customization special modes
all right i want to talk about this uh
opening cutscene uh a little bit but i
also want to mention
that this is running on a playstation 4
as far as i know the only platform this
is available
for is a playstation 4 and we'll maybe
talk about the benefits of that a little
bit later on
but so far opening scene definitely
looks pretty good to me
i like the way that the environment
feels here
the rays of sunshine here are
all very dynamic these shadows you can
see here
as the leaves actually move with the
wind
they're all changing which of course
tells me they're dynamic
all of the leaves falling down are
really cool it's interesting to see
where the leaves end up i'm sure they
don't end up on the ground
if i had to say something that i don't
like about this
and that i think could be done better
with this in terms of like just
environment art is the actual leaves on
the ground they look
quite flat and i doubt that their
actual geometry they might be
but even so i feel like the leaves on
the ground they're gonna stay on the
ground
as far as i know at least from watching
this opening shot here they're most
likely static
so i think making them a little bit more
you know
3d maybe with some displacement mapping
or something like that
would have probably sold this a little
bit
more this kind of autumny warm color
vibe though
i really really like and that blue sky
off in the background i think the
composition of the scene is is really
beautiful
[Music]
wow that's really beautiful i love the
grass the grass looks incredible
all of the foliage looks incredible the
uh the clouds off in the background a
little building off in the background
this is this is this is excellent and i
love the i love the light and the kind
of bloom
style effect that they've got going on
as well
i don't know what would you even call
that like kind of a lens flare i guess
because it's from the brightness of the
light
i think they've done an excellent job
with fading
out the scene so when you look off into
the distance and you see these
trees are kind of you know they're off
in the fog there there's just this
natural fog that's everywhere and
because of that when we look at areas
that are
further away from the camera and thus we
can't really afford to
spend as much time rendering them they
still look great
i'm noticing this line of trees here
they look great i mean obviously there's
probably no detail in the grass but that
doesn't bother me at all
the fire and that particle kind of
system in the background looks really
good as well but these houses as well
they're off there in the fog but it
feels natural to me
this feels like it could be a photo to
me whereas if we look at the fog in the
halo video that we
looked at recently that was very that
was just that just hit me like a
wrecking ball this
on the other hand feels a lot more
natural
and i love that has been at the heart of
our open world design since the victim
this kind of rock the nearby rocks
though
they i don't know maybe i'm just looking
at like unreal engine 5 and a few
other a few other kind of more next-gen
things because this is a playstation 4
game don't forget that
um maybe i'm being a little bit spoiled
but i feel like the detail here is kind
of like
could be improved very beginning
but you can't have exploration if you
don't have curiosity
i love the cloth physics we've
continually asked ourselves
how can we let the island guide you in
the most thematic
and immersive ways possible
the grass whilst i did say the grass
looked really good to me
in the beginning this this looks
doesn't look bad and i feel i feel like
a disclaimer's coming upon us i feel
like i need to say that
so far this looks great i'm hope i'm not
offending anyone
who either worked on the game or really
loves the game so far this looks great
this looks great out of 10 but obviously
me coming into this i'm going to try and
find flaws in it and also point out
things that stick out to me
and one of the things that sticks out to
me here is the fact that
we've got an obvious kind of base grass
texture which is just lying on top of
this rock here you can see it kind of in
the background
and then on top of that we have the
actual grass geometry
and the grass geometry which is most
likely just kind of instanced with some
kind of vertex shader
most likely uh actually making its way
in the wind here
there's kind of nothing in between there
the animation is great don't get me
wrong i love the way that they've done
the grass animation here
but it also just it also kind of just
there's no
for me it doesn't blend very well and
maybe that's because there's no
like layer of smaller grass there's just
a
like these grass blades are huge they
are very big like if you look at his leg
they come up halfway up his calf
probably like it's it's not
they're not small but then the ones that
are
on the rock really flat they are super
small
and like well because they're not
existing right it's just a flat texture
and the texture looks particularly flat
as well
um and because of that there's nothing
in between there's these huge grass
place and then there's like the
supposedly tiny ones but they're
completely flat and so as the camera
moves especially and you get to see that
there's nothing in between blending them
maybe having a layer of smaller grass
blades in between would make it look
better but then again you know maybe
these aren't even grass blades they
could be just
like they could just be you know
this kind of tall grass foliage type
deal not
grass per se it's the very beginning but
anyway so we've continually asked
ourselves
i think if i like i think if i was
designing the scene and i looked at this
um and again you know i mean i don't
know what's possible for playstation 4
on this scene you know it's not like i
have the
profiling data in front of me and i'm
like oh yeah we have room for this
in terms of like draw calls or like how
much time the gp or the cpu are spending
on this i can figure out okay we can
squeeze out some more resources from
this so let's add this in
maybe they're at the at the end of their
budget like in terms of frame
time and this is the best they can do in
which case it's fine and what i'm saying
probably
is anyway enough for the disclaimers you
guys get me i'm not trying to be mean
just just
take everything i say positively okay
how can we let the island guide you
in the most thematic and immersive ways
possible
what he's talking about as well with the
whole uh island i guess being
um how should i say this like the whole
island is b is quite like explorable
right it's all about exploration
that is really cool to me i love stuff
like that
i love the fact that we have this what
looks like a very beautiful
environment but there's also like smoke
and there's this mystery
going on here being able to explore that
as the player
um that like to me that's really that
really that's really like appealing and
i would i don't know like i mean i
haven't seen much of this game but
we'll see how it goes maybe i'll pick it
up
i love the lighting the lighting is so
[Music]
nice
the leaves blowing around really really
nice
and see the thing is getting a few
leaves on screen like
like right now that doesn't cost
anything
like that is not even probably going to
show up
on like a profile of where on earth the
frame time is being spent here
i think that like adding that is
almost free and it
it does so much that's why when ratchet
and clank
when i was looking at that and i was
seeing all the particles flying around i
mean
you know you don't want to go overboard
either because it's just unrealistic
but it can do so like just throwing a
few particles in
can just do so much for a scene and it's
so
it's it's almost like it's it's almost
free in terms of performance and it
probably wouldn't take too long to
actually
implement so it's just it's such a good
thing to do you know
and i love i love how it feels with this
scene imagine it without this it would
feel a little bit
a little bit more empty
notice how the gust of wind affects all
the foliage as well
that's re that's a really cool detail
okay when he lands the like a little
uh grass particle explosion as well
that's really
that's a cool detail horse lighting
and the hair kind of effects here are
well let's just say they're ps4 gen
this is funny because he's completely in
shadow now and that's exactly what
people have been saying is the problem
with halo infinite but
i mean and and i won't go into my
thoughts on the whole in shadow
necessarily looks bad thing
maybe i will in the future but in this
case you can definitely see the
difference between direct sunlight
and shadow here definitely just looks it
does
look different and it does look worse
i expect when the horse appears out of
shadow it will look
nicer
i love the shadows i really like the
dynamic shadows i wonder what technique
they're using for that
i mean it's we're not close enough to
the shadow to actually see what the
edges look like and how soft it is but
right now it looks great okay i'm just
gonna i'm just looking at the shadow
slightly
could be basic like pcf filtering to be
honest
okay this is amazing look at all the
particles flying around
i love that i love the kind of fog wind
effects i don't even know what that is
technically but it looks great
[Music]
that just the ambience you know of this
fog
kind of situation and the clouds and
just
the composition of this scene like i
expected
that they're going for a fairly
photorealistic vibe and i really feel
that because
it it feels like it feels like the way
that they've designed this scene
in terms of especially the lighting and
the colors and you know the clouds and
all of that stuff is is very realistic
um and it goes a lot it goes a long way
because even though they've got a lot of
even though they've got a lot of colors
here you know
it doesn't feel fake at all even though
they've got a lot of colors here
the saturation of this scene is
fairly low right these green trees
here and this kind of the luminance of
them as well the dark kind of green
parts as well
they're not overly green you know same
with the clouds and the sky
it's not overly blue it's it's a really
nice balance and these trees in the
background as well
and it's interesting what you can
achieve just by playing with colors
if your let's just say color skill level
is not particularly high then you can
make a lot of
mistakes and you can make the scene look
a lot less realistic
even with amazing lighting amazing
shadows all of that stuff
but just by either playing with the
source colors the base colors of all of
your albedo
maps and stuff like that as well as
maybe adding like color correction and
color grading filters on top of that
like in as like a post effect that stuff
i think people underestimate that to be
honest that does a lot
and you can see it here
i love the foliage
i love the flowers and all of that stuff
bamboo i want to go to japan again
too bad no one can travel like the next
10 years
[Music]
i'm also looking for like pop in and
like in general how
stuff is being how stuff is changing how
geometry and how the environment is
changing when the when the actual camera
gets closer to a different
part of it and it's
it's done really well i think i can see
some of the
shadow cascades popping maybe
i don't want to go back and analyze this
too much though
can take you to all kinds of locations
in the game like this farmstead that's
been taken over by the mongols it
reminds me a little bit of the witcher
the way that the ui looks maybe and
just moments in general the horse rides
and collectibles
but what about the things that you don't
know about you haven't seen yet that you
don't know exist
keep your eyes peeled for other visual
cues smoke stacks on the horizons
interesting and odd-shaped trees or
maybe even animals trying to get your
attention
quickly yeah that's great i love games
that
integrate um essentially as he said
guides
into the actual environment of the game
so instead of having a pop-up in the ui
being like hey go over there
like actually a visual clue from the
environment like smoke
or like he said like an oddly shaped
tree or something like that
that's yeah that's always the best way
to go
makes it so much more immersive and also
i guess this is this is gameplay right
there's no hud i just realized there's
very little ui i mean there's stuff like
the titles popping up i think a little
bit before as well
there were yeah like this stuff up here
but in general like there's
very little there's no ui in this shot
that's cool definitely cool
no a bird some birds will lead gin to
points of interest
that's cool that's what i mean bird
better than arrow confirmed
[Music]
stay away my lord the spirit of vengeful
samurai
haunt this forest
let's go
um those shadows look a little weak
so do these but you know that that's
what i for current gen shadows that's
pretty much standard shadows and
without ray tracing it's very difficult
to do good dynamic shadows
yeah that's that's classic this shadow
is part of the reason why i don't have
shadows in hazel yet is because i
i'm still kind of trying to maybe find a
technique or
modify a few techniques to try and get
you know shadows to the level that i
actually like them without ray tracing
but it's
it's difficult
i like the level of bloom that they're
using by the way
i feel like games but games pretty much
have bloomed down nowadays
i feel like it's you know it's the first
games with bloom like 15 years ago that
were like
over using it this is quite a lot of
bloom here
but it looks good like this is i'd say
that's perfect to mount because
it you know out of the corner of your
eye it's noticeable it adds to the scene
it but it doesn't make it like
ridiculous and fake to look at it's
really nice
the adaptive exposure they're using is
really smooth as well
again pretty standard but still i
appreciate that
was that like a fox fox then
ah this game is beautiful the way that
it's designed with the sun
with like the the sun i guess the gaps
in the trees making the sun come through
is just this is a recipe for a beautiful
scene
this looks a little weak these things
slapping around in the wind they're like
two-dimensional essentially
that was beautiful with exploration and
discovery and whether you're just
following a string of tour gates that'll
lead you to a high mountain shrine
or maybe it's just the fox trying to
show you something hidden in the woods
i love the fox either way i love the
animals the foxes
and let the wind guide you oh that's
nice
i love these these limited color
palettes shots that they're showing like
where you know there's pretty much just
green here
you know everything's fairly desaturated
but the green is just everywhere here it
honestly i know this i know this game
has like some kind of photo mode
where you can take photos of stuff uh uh
i haven't seen it yet but i can
definitely imagine it
that ah this is a perfect scene this is
i don't know i don't know what i would
do to this to improve it
i actually don't know like look at this
what would you do leave a comment below
if you would if you could think of
something to do to this to improve this
right now
i have zero i actually have zero
those trees in the background just look
did they just look real like i
i love this shot this is what this is my
favorite shot so far
oh and i love him releasing the orange
kind of colored red colored
leaf there autumn is also like
pretty much the the most beautiful
season or fall
for you like americans out there um so
that's also a beautiful
time to set this
i don't know if it's actually set in
autumn but there's a lot of autumn
colors
ah again with the desaturation see that
that's really cool
it's really cool and like i think the
reason why i'm saying it's really cool
because descent like don't get me wrong
desaturation
a lot of times like you know it can come
off a little bit
like amateur you know it reminds me of
like when
kids would be making little like films
back in the day
and probably they're probably still
doing it now it's just that i'm not a
kid anymore but
um you know they would basically you
know how would they get the film look
they'd
you know put their footage into like
premiere or whatever
and then just desaturate it and then add
the contrast you know
and a lot of times obviously that would
that technically does add a bit of a
film look
maybe i mean i don't know if upping the
contrast necessarily would but anyway it
doesn't matter we're not discussing that
now anyway point is
sometimes desaturation like that gives
off that vibe to me
but this is done really well and note
that there's no oval there's no
the contrast is good the contrast is
balanced there's no
harsh blacks and there's no crushed
colors here
it's very well balanced in terms of
dynamic range
i think they've done a really good job
at that honestly
oh look at that reflection here we go
that's beautiful most likely screen
space
but beautiful
all right we're gonna end off this video
here let me know what you guys thought
i'm seven minutes into this if you want
to see a follow-up video
in this same style or perhaps in a
different stuff you want me to look at
something specific if you don't like the
way that i'm talking if you don't like
what i'm discussing and you want me to
maybe get my view on something else
leave a comment below
and i will take a look at it next time i
definitely want to continue doing this
maybe in a couple days or so i might
release a follow up uh with maybe the
rest of this but if you have like a
favorite feature that you're really
interested in how
how i think they achieved that or if
there's something visual that you're
not sure how it works also leave a
comment below and i'll try and explain
it next video when we continue
looking at this but i hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
don't forget to hit the like button
there's so much stuff that i want to
look at in the coming future because i
think that we're getting some really
really
cool games both coming out now and being
promised for the future
so it's not gonna be long i'll see you
guys soon goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you